first of all it's fascinating to think
about this context
uh in terms of uh evolving architectures
so i've studied tesla autopilot for a
long time
it's one particular implementation of an
ai system that's operating in the real
world i find it fascinating because of
the scale at which it's used out in the
real world
and uh i'm not sure if you're familiar
with that system much but
you know andre kapati leads that team on
the machine learning side
and there's a multi-task network
multi-headed network where there's a
core
but it's trained on particular tasks and
there's a bunch of different heads that
are trained on that
is there some lessons from
evolutionary computation or neural
evolution that could be applied to this
kind of
multi-headed beast that's operating in
the real world yes
it's a very good problem for new
revolution
and the reason is that when you have
multiple tasks
they support each other so let's say
you're
learning to classify extra images
different pathologies so you have one
task is to classify
this disease and another one this
disease another on this one and when
you're learning
from one disease that forces certain
kinds of internal representations and
embeddings
and they can serve as a helpful starting
point for the other tasks
so you are combining the wisdom of
multiple tasks into these
representations
and it turns out that you can do better
in each of these tasks
when you're learning simultaneously
other tasks than you would by one task
alone which is a fascinating
idea in itself yeah yes and and people
do that all the time i mean you use
knowledge of domains that you know
in new domains uh and and certainly
neural networks can do that
when your evolution comes in is that um
what's the best way to combine
these tasks now there's architectural
design that allow you to decide where
and how the the embeddings the internal
representations are combined
and how much you combine uh them uh and
uh there's quite a bit of research on
that and and my team elliott mayerson's
worked on that
um in particular like what is a good
internal representation
that supports multiple tasks uh and
we're
getting to understand how that's
constructed and what's in it
so that it is in a space that supports
multiple
different heads like you said um and
and that i think is fundamentally how
biological intelligence works as well
you don't build a representation just
for one task you try to build something
that's general
not only so that you can do better in
one task or multiple tasks but also
future tasks and future challenges so
you learn to learn the structure of
of the world and and that helps you uh
in all kinds of future future challenges
and so you're trying to design a
representation that will support
an arbitrary set of tasks in a
particular sort of class of problem
yeah and and also it turns out and
that's again a surprise that eliot found
was that those tasks don't have to be
very related
you know you can learn to do better
vision by learning language
or better language by learning about dna
structure
no somehow the world
yeah it rhymes the world rhymes even
it's very uh
very desperate fields
you